when you say you were depressed as a kid
was it to the point of uh being suicidal
i just don't see a reason to live like i
can't get out of bed that's a tough
question man it's tough to talk about
um
i remember
um
like almost my
entire
i'd say the last
year of middle school the first
the first year of high school was
i didn't sit with anybody at the lunch
table and i just sat there with my head
in my hands and i was just like i don't
know and i don't understand and i don't
know what the [ __ ] is going on with
anyone did you go to your parents and
say listen man i'm in trouble i'm not
sir
right you can't go to anybody it feels
like there's no one yeah it's the worst
yes sir and and i know there's a lot of
lonely people and there's
um
um [ __ ] trillion billion lonely
people in the world and i just want to
say that there's um always someone who
[ __ ] loves you and you don't have to
be scared to talk about it what pulled
you out i mean did you go on medication
or did you um did you what did you do to
pull yourself out of this depression
that you're in
it was music
music took me out yes sir to get to your
level to be a professional musician if
you start on guitar hero which is a
video game
and then you teach yourself somehow to
play the real thing after one lesson and
i imagine you'd teach yourself by what
were you you're sitting there
practicing a metallica song or something
or well you're like what i don't get how
you get to that point it's never been
explained to me
it was definitely uh ultimateguitar.com
like i remember it was either whenever i
was a kid it was either porn or
ultimateguitar.com
yeah
and and i missed out the memo on
ultimateguitar.com i was just into porn
but seriously it is really quite
remarkable the level of musicianship for
a guy who locked himself in a room
and then does that what happens to you
in school all of a sudden you start to
perform in front of other people i
remember the first time i got drunk and
they had a guitar so i got out my guitar
and i started singing because i was
hammered this was the first time i got
drunk off sir peach
sorak peach and that is like
worst [ __ ] in the
and now whenever universe smell that
[ __ ] yeah i'm like hey jaeger i can do
so rock peach is like out of this
universe but i i got drunk and i was
like whoa so so all of a sudden
you're so wasted
you pull out the guitar and you and and
these dudes and girls they had no idea
you were into the guitar they didn't
know anything about it
and you start playing what
wicked games by the weekend and people
were like oh [ __ ] right they're like
this is really good this is actually
good yeah so the point is
music saved your life
very much so